an in-depth look at a very deep problem
here in southern nevada today clark
county commissioners got a detailed
state overview
on homelessness other governments here
in southern nevada are going to get the
same report
and it outlines the problem with
homelessness and tries to point to some
solutions
our bianca holmen live this afternoon
with details on that bianca
thousands sleep on the streets each
night across the valley
and clark county leaders they want to
change that and they actually just
approve
efforts to get those folks into some
warm beds and onto a path of success
now currently we have a tiered approach
combining
housing mental health addiction and case
management but for that approach
there's a funding gap during the meeting
a working group shared a report
detailing methods to reduce homelessness
and additional resources
of money because you've got to have
something to pay for the report also
included there's a shortage of 78
thousand affordable housing units across
the valley give credit
for inclusion of behavioral health
housing is obviously critical we have to
increase our housing supply but if we
don't
consider the other aspects that go along
with homelessness
then we have will have failed and i
think these numbers really speak to the
enormous gap that we have in both
housing and uh providing behavioral
health services
here in southern nevada
now the board of commissioners they
approved the report and its
recommendations
and this was a team that was a product
from the 80th nevada
legislature session assembly bill 73.
reporting from grand central in
bonneville bianca holman 8 news now